on va passer aux invités du soir on va
recevoir dans un instant le président
des républicains qui fait énormément
parler l'homme qu'il fallait avoir
aujourd'hui Eric sootti avec lu on va
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé ce
weekend à roman surizer une semaine
après la mort de Thomas dans la commune
voisine de crpol plusieurs militants de
l'ultradroite se sont réunis dans le
quartier où plusieurs des agresseurs de
Thomas réside bat de baseball barre de
fer affrontement avec les forces de
l'ordre l'objectif est clair une
expédition punitive pour selon eu venger
la mort de Thomas on va voir une compile
des images à roman surzer et dans un
instant Éric siioti sera avec nous avant
d'écouter je vous demander votre avis il
a refusé de condamner ce qui s'est passé
à Roman Surer là ce
weekendti dire si vous êtes d'accord
avec lui ou pas sur il peut en avoir qui
sont d'accord avec lui et erti viendra
nous rejoindre juste après petit
comp
[Applaudissements]
moi je pense qu'il va condamner merci
Éric soti d'être avec nous président des
républicains merci d'être là il y a
énormément de sujets aborder
actuellement et ce soir c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde voulait
avoir Eric CTI sur son plateau je
voudrais écouter Daniel qui vous êtes
vous êtes oui mais non mais quand même
c'est important on va revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé et bien sûr on va poser la
question Eric soti qui refuse de cond ce
qui s'est passé à roman surzer il va
nous dire pourquoi mais vous êtes un peu
d'accord avec lui je trouve incroyable
le traitement de ça alors je je condamne
évidemment si ces gens sont venus
vraiment avec des mauvaises intentions
moi ce que je vois c'était une marche
pour Thomas alors d'accord il y avait
des fumigènes mais apparemment il ne
portait pas d'armes sur eux la seule
victime c'est quelqu'un qui a été lynché
et humilié imaginz pendant les émeutes
de naë si si ça avait été le contraire
je pense qu'on en aurait parlé encore
aujourd'hui donc je trouve que le
traitement médiatique et et cette
affaire pour pour l'instant est un petit
peu monté en épingle et arrange
certainement beaucoup de gens voilà
alors on va revenir sur tout ça plus
d'une semaine après la mort de Thomas
lors d'une fête à Crépol dans la Drome
on a tous parlé de de Thas vous pouvez
garder vos pancartes he bien entendu une
manifestation appelée par des militants
d'ultra drroite a eu lieu dans une ville
voisine à Roman suriser Sam soir il est
environ 18h euh dans le quartier de la
monnaie quartier d'où viennent quelques
personnes interpellées dans l'affaire de
la mort de Thomas et 80 militants d'ultr
drroite se sont réunis avec pour
objectif de faire justice pour Thomas
des personnes en cagoulé habillé tout en
noir euh munie de de battes de baseball
de barre de fer ou encore de mortiers
hein Gill c'est ça absolument venu de
toute la France euh il y en avait qui
étaient en comparition immédiate
aujourd'hui donc de 17 à 36 ans des
étudiants un militaire euh parmi ceux
qui étaient jugés aujourd'hui donc un
seul avait un casier euh ils étaient
accusés notamment de violence sur
fonctionnaires de police mais
effectivement ils viennent de toute la
France surtout vous réagirez à chaque
fois la manifestation était en réalité
une récupération de ce que disait disent
des les gens de la mort de Thomas les
banderoles étaient justice pour Thomas
encore justice pour Thomas ni pardon ni
oublie mais d'autres San nationalistes
ont été entendus parmi lesquels la rue
la France nous appartient c'est ça qui a
posé problème g absolument ça a été
considéré par certains pas par Monsieur
chti mais ça a été considéré par
certains comme tout simplement une
expédition punitive une une
ratonnade des affrontements ont eu lieu
avec des forces de l'ordre CIN policiers
ont d'ailleurs été blessés par les tir
de mortier et des pierres du côté des
manifestants un militant de 20 ans a été
tabassé gravement blessé il a été
retrouvé par les pompiers en bordure du
quartier puis transporté à l'hôpital son
pronostic vital n'est pas engagé sorti
de sa voiture tapé contusionné
effectivement emmené à l'hôpital et
pronostic vital pas engagé voilà mais il
a quand même été tabassé le préfet de la
drrome a annoncé 24 gardes à vue ce
weekend et a condamné fortement ce qui
s'est passé écoutez-le les forces de
l'ordre ont réagi avec efficacité appuyé
par la police nationale et avec le
soutien de la police municipale que je
soulligne parce que il y avait aussi la
surveillance des caméras vidéo C donc
tentative de de de rentrer dans le
cartié de moness a été repoussé il y a
eu une vingtaine
d'interpellations dont 17 garde à vue je
me permets de condamner encore une fois
avec une grande force cet excès de
violence il y a eu un drame épouvantable
il y a quelques jours dans un village
aux alentours de R de roman mais ce ne
peut pas expliquer ou en tout cas
valider cette volonté d'en découdre
qu'il y a eu hier soir si jeunes hommes
ont été jugé cet après-midi à Valence en
comparitiontion immédiate ils ont tous
entre 18 et 25 ans ils viennent du dou
de Côte d'Or près de Dijon du gare de
Paris et de Lyon la plupart vivent chez
leurs parents ils sont étudiants
stagiaires chôeurs militaires
développeurs informatique à l'exception
de l'un d'entre eux leur casier
judiciaire et vierge et tous minimise
leur intention ce soir-là les peinnes
vont de 6 à 10 mois de prison ferme Gile
oui oui c'esté un appel national Cyril
qui avait été lancé sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur les boucles télégram de
l'extrême droite donc voilà reste à
savoir maintenant effectivement c'est
pour ça que le débat avec Monsieur sooti
sera passionnant si c'était une
expédition punitive et pourquoi Monsieur
sooti n'a pas condamné si c'est alors la
préfecture du rô a pris la décision
d'interdire une manifestation prévue
aujourd'hui à Lyon le rassemblement
organisé par plusieurs groupes d'ultr
droite et notamment les remparts de Lyon
devaient avoir lieu sur la place du
maréchal bioté après la mort de Thomas
tué à crpol il y a plus d'une semaine on
va revenir donc sur tout ça et sur
toutes les réactions merci ericti d'être
avec nous vous refusez de condamner ce
qui s'est passé à Roman surizer
pourquoi
cette affaire elle part d'une interview
hier soir sur une chaîne
concurrente où j'ai dit aux journalistes
à plusieurs reprise qu'il fallait pas
tout mettre sur le même plan on a d'un
côté à crépul la mort de Thomas dont on
parle plus ce soir ouis c'est vrai la
mort de la mort de Thomas 16 ans que la
vie appelé capitaine de son équipe de
rugby il y a eu 18 blessés à crépul dont
deux qui ont failli mourir en urgence
absolue qui ont été poignardés dans un
contexte où neuf témoins ont dit qu'il
voulait que ceux qui sont arrivés en
bande organisée voulaient tuer et
planter du blanc et dont le président de
la République a qualifié ses actes
d'assassinat ou ce qui en sens dans le
code pénal assassinat ça veut dire un
meurtre par préméditation donc avec des
notation raciste potentiellement
puisqu'il y a neuf témoins qui disent
que les auteurs de ces faits voulait
tuer du blanc je le redis et il y a
cette affaire que vous évoquez cette
manifestation à roman sur iser on m'a
interrogé en ne parlant que de l'affaire
de roman sur iser et moi je dis qu'il y
a une hiérarchie dans l'information et
que cette affaire de roman
suriser vous j'ai pas refusé de
condamner dans l'émission j'ai condamné
tous ceux qui étaient contraire à la loi
personne ne peut se faire justice
soi-même mais ce qui s'est passé hier
soir n'est pour moi je le redis je le
confirme n'est pas de la même gravité
que l'assassinat de Thomas personne
n'est mort à roman sur iser même si tout
ce qui s'est passé est condamnable hier
soir il y avait pas de condamnation ce
soir la justice est prononcée moi j'ai
dit hier soir j' Ava pas des les
éléments factuels j'ai dit j'attends que
la justice se prononce elle s'est
prononcé et bien des personnes ont été
condamnées la justice est passée c'est à
elle de condamner mais c'est pas à une
forme de tribunal médiatique excité par
Monsieur Mélenchon pour dire ce qui doit
se passer voilà je voudrais connait dans
dans la hiérarchie de l'information le
même traitement le même traitement pour
Thomas clon a eu pour naë le même
traitement de ce qui s'est passé de
condamnaable à roman surizer que de ce
qui s'est passé dans 450 500 quartiers
de France où il y a eu 12000 voitures
brûlé où il y a eu 900 policiers
gendarmes blessés 250 écoles brûlées 150
mairies brûlé et on a l'impression que
c'est la même affaire mais ceux qui
disent ça ils sont pas au contact des
Français parce que ce qui s'est passé à
crépool dans un petit village où un
gamin est mort parce que il y a des
barbares
l'ensauvagement de la société derrière
tout ça c'est pas mon mot c'est le mot
du ministre de l'Intérieur et on met sur
le même plan la la manifestation allez
de crétins bien entendu violents qu'on
peut condamner on a vu leur profil mais
quand même relativisons et aujourd'hui à
cause Dee
parom plus plus personne ne parle de
Thomas et les Français de qui il parlent
il parlent de Thomas et bien moi je veux
être leur porte-parole et c'est pour
cela d'ailleurs que j'ai demandé que
demain à l'Assemblée nationale il y ait
une minute de silence pour Thomas comme
il y en a une pour Naël alors euh ça
c'est une très bonne très bonne
initiative ça il il y a Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui vous a interpellé sur X
Éric sooti président de des républicains
refuse de condamner l'agression de
extrême droite en bande armée contre un
quartier populaire cette ambiguïté avec
le racisme encourage les pires
débordements de violence ce refu est une
apologie pour les bandes armées raciste
on voit de mieux en mieux où est le
problème dans notre République alors
vous l'iavez répondu monsieur mélencher
Monsieur
Mélenchon exz-moi le danger pour la
République c'est vous depuis des années
vous combattez la France éternelle ma
France est celle de Thomas vous préférez
ses bourreaux mais vous ne me trouverez
toujours sur votre chemin qu'est-ce que
vous lui répondrez ce soir parce qu'il
vous en a remis une couche après la la
même chose c'est quand même le plus mal
placé pour tenir ses propos lui qui a
refusé de condamner l'attaque terroriste
islamiste du Hamas qui a fait 1200 morts
qui a tué des enfants qui a tué des
femmes qui a pris en otage des innocents
qui a attaqué des vieillards dans leur
domicile qui les ont brûlé vif il a
refusé de citer c'est barbare de citer
ces mots et là il vient nous donner des
leçons dès que ces gens sont en
difficulté il y a laalibi du danger
d'extrême droite aujourd'hui bien sûr
qu'il y a des dangers mais le principal
danger pour la République c'est Monsieur
Mélenchon et ses SBIR aujourd'hui c'est
ce que je lui dis c'est ce que je lui ai
dit qui menace la République ce sont ces
idiots qui ont manifester qu'on doit
condamner qui ont été condamnés ou c'est
ceux qui aujourd'hui banalisent la
violence cré aujourdhu par leur discours
des tenstions s'appuie sur la montée du
communautarisme islamiste pour des
raison électorale voilà la réalité c'est
une expédition punitive quand même à
roman suriser ou pasce qui s'est passé
sans doute mais qui a été puni pour
qu'il y ait une expédition punitive il
faut qu'il y ait des gens qui étaient
punis heureusement les forces peut-être
peut les forces de l'ordre ont fait leur
travail et heureusement heureusement
qu'elles étaient là heureusement
qu'elles étaient là mais encore une fois
l'hypocrisie de Mélenchon voilà le de
poid de mesure moi je suppporte plus
quand vous entendez des gens de
d'extrême gauche qui dit que c'était qui
disent que le enfin le drame de Thomas C
Rix vous leur dites quoi mais c'était
pas on voit bien la
banalisation et puis après on cherche
c'est ce qui se passe avec roman sur
rizer on cherche une
dérivation pour oublier tout ça
finalement n'a pas d'importance